foreign
Chuck what do you know about Medusa
um
I don't want to see her
I know that if
if she ever said to me uh look here I'm
like no
I'm not looking no I'm not looking to me
look here
yeah she makes eye contact with you you
turn to Stone right she's famously in
the night sky she's immortalized the
severed head of Medusa is immortalized
held by the Perseus Perseus is a
constellation in the sky and there's a
star called algol which is a variable
star it changes its brightness
over relatively short periods of time
that's why we call them variable stars
and the eye of the severed head is algol
so this is Medusa like looking at you
it's pretty fun and of course Perseus
was the hero in the story with Andromeda
who is the daughter of Cassiopeia and
she was I don't remember why oh
Cassiopeia said she was more beautiful
than the sea nymphs and then then out of
punishment the they took her daughter
and strapped her to the cliffs and for
the sea monster to come devour her and
Perseus the Kraken right and so the
Perseus comes to save to save her but he
can't get there on foot so out of the
Sea Foam Rises up Rises up uh Pegasus
Pegasus and he flies on the back of
Pegasus oh he has to slay Medusa all
right right and so he does it by
looking at her but through the
reflection of his shield right and that
way it's not a direct direct sight line
I can't believe yourself for that
and so you know and backs up to it slays
her backwards right that was very cool
and it cuts off her head and puts it in
a in a in a sack Perseus is in the sky
um rides on the back to go save
Andromeda by showing the severed head of
Medusa to the Kraken and the Kraken
turns to Stone and then crumbles away
because he's too big to be Stone right I
gotta say that's a big chance that
Perseus took that you know the severed
head would still be able to do its thing
good yeah yeah rather than just with
closed eyelids right you have to like
pry open the eyelids with toothpicks
because you know a lot of times you know
he had to make sure she died with her
eyes open probably from the surprise the
surprise of falling for that stupid
trick of looking at her through her
Shield so she died with her eyes like I
can't believe that I fell for this like
is that what she sounds like that's
Medusa I can't believe
I fell for this stupid trick perfect
okay so all of them are in the night sky
we got Andromeda Medusa uh Cassiopeia
the reason why I'm saying all this is
there's a whole set of Legends
that derive from the expectation
that when you look at someone or
anything that you're sending out some
beam of energy or information or light
as though seeing was an active
aspect of what it is to obtain
information right so I see you because
because I'm going out there and I'm
getting you right bringing you back in
right right right so that is not how
seeing works and this was not
established until about 1300 years ago
in the Middle East in what we call the
Golden Age of Islam uh al-hazim uh
occasionally referred to as uh al-hason
both of those I think are legitimate
names for him one of the great
scientists of the era an early
scientists in the history of scientists
um kept good notes had hypotheses of how
things worked he looked at a cow eyeball
saw a lens saw that you can make an
image on the back of the eyeball and he
deduced that the active site is 100
passive
all reception
all reception so you can't just give
someone the google eyes and have them
say oh I feel someone's looking at me
people will still say that right all
experiments show that no you cannot tell
if you do it in a controlled setting you
cannot tell when someone's looking at
you unless you're in the subway
because
sometimes in the subway and you just get
that feeling that comes up the back of
your neck and you turn and there is some
creepy person staring at you and they
don't turn away they will not this thing
that's how you know you're in New York
any other place you look at somebody and
they look away like oh shoot I was they
look sheepish about Kevin I can't
believe I was there in New York you turn
at them and they're just like that's
right I'm going to kill you like
oh
don't scare people from the New York
City Subways that's not what here's my
point anytime you turn around because
you think someone's staring at you and
they are staring at you right you have
not recorded the thousands of times
people were also staring at you and you
didn't turn around to notice right okay
so this this is when you do the control
setting this this is the case
so it's just an interesting fact the
Bible stories about who was it that
turned back and she became a pillar of
salt lots of life
is it because she observed or because
the no she the Sodom and Gomorrah the
life from Scotty mcgorry reached her
eyes which was it well I never seen my
Bible stories here no no that was
correct it was it was actually both of
that both those things she observed the
destruction of Sodom and Gomorrah and
they were told whatever you do do not
look back
and so she violated the the directive
looked back at the destruction and
turned to stone in doing so okay so that
case that might not be her sending out a
signal from her eyeballs so that sounds
like a more legit uh consequence of this
right relative to Medusa looking at you
right your eyes light up and then you
turn to Stone so so I just it's an
interesting history how you can there
can be mythologies that rise up around
physiological misconceptions that make
for interesting stories right right and
people used to be thought of as dying of
a broken heart all right uh maybe it was
an actual heart attack all right but and
you know there it was bacon it was bacon
but Francis Bacon or bacon was just
Baconator
like he died of [__] heart no no
that's not too much that's called
cholesterol the man had bacon with every
single meal and you know you can't do
but you can't you don't want to take
away the romance of dying of a broken
heart that's all yeah so it's just it's
just fun so I don't I don't object to
misconceptions if you have no better
explanation at the time and it becomes
part of a field of our cultural sense of
the world I mean that's this is what
um this is the richness and the depth of
history that we experience as a culture
who knows what they were saying about
that was the problem with that though
what
someone of your particular acuity
can say that
can say this is part of the wondrous
Romance of Life
farming Elements of Life that we're able
because you're a person who understands
the scientific method you're somebody
who uh you know believes in data and
empiricism you know both okay
but the problem with that that Charming
that wonder that you know these these
these idiosyncratic you know things that
happen
um that we attribute meaning to them you
know that we're attributing that meaning
we are affixing meaning to those things
they don't really have meaning the
problem is there are a bunch of
dumbasses
he's [__] who actually believe
okay they believe this
once we've learned how all this works
there's no excuse to continue to think
it's true and that's what you're talking
about the people who are are delayed in
their acceptance of objective realities
and I'm with you there but I'm not going
to judge people from long ago on today's
standards oh okay all right I'm gonna
say okay no no you got me yeah that's
that's we got to give it to you there
they're perfectly acceptable they had no
other information so therefore boom I
get it exactly exactly and you know
right on down to those who imagined that
someone have any epileptic seizure were
being invaded by the devil right right
and so you go get the priest and they do
the holy water right and and then
symptoms right the seizures over the
20-minute seizure ends it just ended
because how far away is the church 500
years ago it's like two blocks away
right just in time for the priest to get
there so I it's it's we're trying to
make sense of the world and I so I don't
you know I'm so funny you use that that
as an example because I think it's a
great example because we can actually
see the brain now we can see the
activity of the brain and exactly what
is happening in the brain that causes
this epileptic fit so there is we're not
seeing the devil what we're seeing is a
neurosynaptic breakdown or malfunction
right and so you know but where did the
devil go you know it like right right
but if fine in the face of science just
don't lead any science agencies that
allocate research
play a job for you if it's in a society
all right Chuck we got to end it there
all right this
it's been yet another star talk
explainer on some random subject you
never thought you might be interested in
and maybe you're still not
who am I to tell Neil the grass Tyson
here as always keep looking up
[Music]